maybe wants me to like find what you
need to get some hated here yeah but I
really trust his name real time that's
nice - what something survived jumping
out at sea 90% of game
well yeah I'm scared so it's gonna go do
it I'm not scared so much racket jumpy
well we're gonna light the fire
yeah I guess I haven't been particularly
scared yet but I'm anxious
check out this gun hand hands over your
heads nice show show definitely I feel
like he would it's it's tough because
you get to choose I always try and
choose things based on what I think the
character would do alright I'm just
trying to make it nice for ya real nice
do you like matches made America suspect
up we know he's an American that's what
that's it and mom's mother been returned
she was enraged and tell us imagine but
he managed to escape with her cubs pets
and Mighty Eagle so innocent stripped of
emotion as she ran through the streets
but a gunshot frightened me even the
diagonals even the horses won't even see
me but a great tree felled looking his
way something something yeah so we have
it that's a water spell particularly
against evil spirits a vision or dream
with features the butterfly that's the
one it's within the total spell
protecting points yeah so because
against evil that's good so just on this
side and it also kind of confirmed that
there was a giant bear I really I really
don't think the plains realized that guy
do you think the flame thrower God is
Victor yeah definitely
what is it just makes how about agent
repost his hands
yeah just me and something ground oh
wait maybe can I see I can't read that
evil thing is to threat spirits he's old
like it doesn't let me move his hands or
anything
okay so let's read the Chuck in its
Native American hunters use citizen
science scratched on the trees abdominal
walls to communicate without the Travis
many symbols can main religious or
mystical beliefs others warn of danger
of protection we kind of already know
that eat and that's what I think
flamethrower guy is Native American and
it's not a bad guy don't know what he's
chasing them very particular let me be
following them around trying
particularly something else maybe that
on
maybe he knows the knife presents my
particular from the knife die then
what's the second ear deceitful of him
being Native American just person that's
really nice maybe he's using the flame
to attack the Bears that just referenced
monster bears which should be asleep
they should be in hibernation the water
should be frozen both of those things
are giant fuck-ups glossing over that he
couldn't be could be good all right
that's that's what I'm telling myself
again this is all confirmation bias I'm
trying to find me like some damn fire
another one is you just need to like it
was a [ __ ] Oh peaceful
- here but he totally does things by one
Mitch single - this is gonna be handy
demand like worked very well that's
simplify its work you know I wish I
never thought that I like that okay this
is Victor or a bear outside right now
well surely come
but for whatever reason I've convinced
myself and I'm not scared
so still really cold the fire's just
such a good file now there's instantly
want the entire mer
the he's not attractive anymore
what are you wearing likewise Peter
I feel like this is just a creative way
for them to show us since he's he's more
it's alright he's more interactive he
got on a pasta she's a little bit late
just moves faster than her
me it wants me to be but yeah this other
both it's not going to be take any X if
you know doesn't that white boy I it's
Lou yeah
still missing patient
[ __ ] so whatever it is just get inside
well that's it fun that's creepy
that's really creepy joining it he's
nice Victor's nice he was returning a
full business yeah can you just don't
say that
you idiot
how's the canoe to be that way
okay weird thing for he would say Victor
is not nice
oh my god this because she wasn't being
nice it was not expecting that
holy [ __ ] she was being hateful
everything that I've said is incorrect
she was beautiful
Danica I just think that he was gonna
murder anyone why would he ripped her
through a window maybe he's not a good
guy at all and I was completely wrong
this entire time okay
alright this is great straight we don't
know that she's dead yet because there
was that thing when she woke up on the
floor yeah but she might not be dead but
if she's not it's not the biggest mess
you know it's not okay waste of space
actually yeah maybe not in the library
or is there more than one or there's
books but it looks like a really big
room it's not so strange
it's all fine I'm not talking find your
way around anything it's not clear okay
it could partly be because the camera is
strange at the time there forward to
starting it takes you mhm because it's
just swapping is it trying to
oh that's a spiritual that's yes thanks
he doesn't seem real estate Chris does
he know it not is not like you know I'm
like Josh this freaked out Weiss a bit
freaked out you don't know what that
meant but we have no idea when that is
why do separate I'll see you guys for me
don't worry I'm 11 Maximus it was a
minute this
when we spin around bows it's been
brother flying around
spin-spin-spin ah the control the spirit
ah what the [ __ ] I will take them and
leave them like pigs and rip this soft
white skin off [ __ ] 16 years 16 years
I waited for pre little Hanna and Beth
were sixteen oh okay
so we don't so this means someone had
wanted to kill him for a really long
time if they've been going up there hmm
so that person did want to kill them we
don't know who's still that person well
no I think that Victor repeating I think
it's Victor who's the point yeah I hope
the reason anything that is because we
found it was a note at the start of the
cabin clean the the the trolley think
that way and that said they wanted for
us in 40 years or something yeah honey
they couldn't find one in a six foot son
so yeah six foot - Greg so we think that
Victor is the pyro Victor is also
currently following Mike and Jess or
just ripped jestro in there presumably
because we know that because he had the
same vision as he had beforehand I feel
like these are logical things to piece
together yeah the same red vision as
when he was following her in bed so
that's all Victor this we don't know if
it's Victor you know so here's here's
definitely an American so soft lights
you know or Native American which is
what we think which would mean that it's
also probably Victor but it's been there
for a long time forty years I think it's
a forty years how long it's been since
they founded which also rules out Josh
so I think yeah we just have one bad guy
and it is flamethrower guy is what I'm
thinking
holy cow so this is a living point which
one I don't understand you should go
well that's what this parable it told
them to find can't imagine they're
supposed to find that does it was once
yours open stop doing that
keep zooming in their faces when I'm not
touching it all right dog was what she
tried it
yeah oh just keep waiting for
jump-scares all the time
it's Native American stuff everywhere in
here
that's really weird yes so where are we
going right now looking for Jewish we're
doing its best to be showing Josh the
thing yeah wait it looks brighter up
there though that's just did you see his
hands well the thing that pulled through
with his clothes actually maybe it was
in business the best don't really do
that please don't okay okay so do you
think the fair was getting really upset
a bit whoo yeah it was like what just
wear something public showing the hive
an idea and if he difficult stop wanting
it [ __ ]
yeah that's by the way yeah
so we'd established this game has
supernatural aspects because I believe
that we need what was Hannah it's art
this wasn't fun dude - exactly
cuz I know she was dead in the hallway
she was sitting
oh you think that was her beyond yeah I
think that she was standing around
because it just looked like a dead chick
that's take care of my face we just
don't so then I the idea of this home
wants to be a concept that's been
introduced to some kind of Native
American historical things could also be
part of the cinematics maybe is a
massive massive better Chris with its
creepy cool
that's how bad guy okay just get real
all right
[ __ ] this is the nice thing yeah I think
that's not God have we [ __ ] up
did I do something wrong to make this
happen why is this happened shake he
pretended he was Josh that's why she
went through the door we are going to
look for Josh again I keep is that Josh
controls it could be Josh but then
there's the whole weight of 16 [ __ ]
years thing I'm confused
but do you I'm really confused cool I
hope that I didn't just kill someone so
I don't think they did I think if they
did they'll obviously be doing right I
feel like I didn't do anything wrong
Josh wasn't in there
it was just Christian - Josh wasn't me
that makes me think it's Josh but it's
in like Josh's voice with the door
that's why she wins because it could be
Josh let's do this we got this down wet
judgmental it's hip
to give up this information no this is
an excel honestly I think it will play
better at me rice yeah time just fight
we don't wanting to give him the honest
answer
so between those two we like Sam yeah so
dramatically proposing
dramatic people sing that [ __ ] it
Chris yeah I feel like we know more of
Chris yeah she's actually just worries
all the time unlike fish I don't dislike
her
Mike Mike there's a douche yeah but just
it's just offensive just tell me Rob
counting all the sections from bad rude
and that's tough I still don't like Josh
so I think the reason we'd have another
choice yeah look between those I think
that I would choose Josh I find him
cruelly
but it's also just that we've decided
you know hits things a killer we could
be completely wrong
whereas Emily isn't our I'll is the bish
she's a [ __ ]
true okay yeah yeah
actually yeah we don't want just
tell me Emily
yeah yeah we reveal this because it's
just this we already yes yes yes yeah
freighter out of time talk against